This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6-Mate English
From BBC Learning English
Hello, this is 6 Minute English
from BBC Learning English. I'm Rob.
And I'm Sam.
Have you got a business brain, Sam?
Would you like to start your own business?
It sounds good, Rob. I like the idea of being my own boss.
Well, that's the dream for many millennials.
The name given to the current generation of young people,
aged between 24 and 38.
Some of the millennial generation are dissatisfied
with the old ways of doing things.
For example, how big business uses data from social media
and the negative impact of companies on society and the environment.
In today's programme, we'll look at why millennials are so attracted
to starting their own businesses
and asking whether this really is the way to make the world a better place.
And of course, we'll be learning some new vocabulary on the way.
But first, it's time for today's quiz question.
At 79 years old, Mohamed Yunus is hardly a millennial,
but he's a hero to many young business people.
In 2006, he won the Nobel Peace Prize.
But what for? Was it for a offering microfinance to low-income businesses?
Be starting the first business to earn £1 million in under a week,
or see developing a progressive model of taxation.
I know millennials like starting businesses,
so I'll say be earning £1 million in under a week.
Okay, we'll find out later if you were right.
Now, whether it's TV shows like The Apprentice,
or the big success of companies in California's Silicon Valley,
the last decades are a huge growth in 20 and 30-year-olds starting their own businesses.
BBC World Service Programme The Wife Actor
asked Business Professor Ethan Mollick to explain how this situation came about.
There's all these platforms that let you build entrepreneurial ventures,
much more easily. The growth of things like crowdfunding
have helped make entrepreneurship more accessible,
and led to tons of new startups.
So there's a lot of new methods for launching businesses,
and the cost of launching businesses dropped at the same time.
Ethan lists some of the reasons why it's now easier to become an entrepreneur,
someone who starts their own business, often after seeing a new opportunity.
Entrepreneurs see opportunities for products and services not being supplied by existing companies,
so they create startups, newly formed businesses intended to grow rapidly
by providing for a particular market gap.
One of the main problems to starting up your own business
used to be getting the large amounts of money needed.
But nowadays, this can be solved with crowdfunding,
getting the funding for a new business by asking a large number of people to give small amounts
of money, usually via the internet.
But while startups' success stories have made going into business a good option,
for many millennials it's not just about making money,
but also about being socially responsible and doing good.
However, others argue that most big changes for the better
have come from governments, not millennial businesses.
Here, former World Bank economist Charles Kenney,
caution against over-emphasising individual business over governments.
If you are working in a place with a corrupt and inefficient government,
one of the best ways you can push development in your countries to try and make that problem
a little bit better, it's not something that anyone individual can do, it has to be a collective
effort. But the more we have, young, committed, smart people who want to make the world a better place,
working in government, the more likely government is to start delivering the kind of services we
need in order to ensure a high quality of life in that country.
So Charles mentions the problem that governments can be corrupt,
acting morally wrong or illegal ways, often in return for money or power.
The talent and passion that millennials put into starting their own business
could instead be used to improve governments through collective effort,
a group of people acting together to achieve a common goal.
It's this working together that can raise people's quality of life,
level of personal satisfaction and comfort.
Something that Muhammad Yunus was doing.
Ah yes, that's today's quiz question. I asked you why Muhammad Yunus won the Nobel Prize
in 2006. I said that B, he started the first business to earn 1 million in under a week.
But in fact, it was A, offering microfinance to low income businesses.
A way for anyone, rich or poor, to run a business in a positive way.
So today we've been talking about why young people in the millennial generation want to be
entrepreneurs, people who start their own business. Many millennials create startups,
newly formed businesses intended to grow rapidly using a method called crowdfunding,
getting the funding for their new business by asking large numbers of people on the internet
to each give a little bit of money.
But it's not only about making profits, millennial startups can help solve many of the developing
world's problems instead of governments which may be corrupt, acting immorally or illegally
for money or power. What's needed more than individual businessmen and women is collective
effort, a group of people acting together to achieve a common goal.
And one important goal is to improve the quality of life, the level of satisfaction and comfort,
that a person or group enjoys. Well, that's all from us today, but remember to join us again
soon for more topical discussion and vocabulary. Bye for now. Bye bye.